my name is Robbie and I'm gonna meet my
birth mother this weekend my parents
were open about the adoption my whole
life I didn't really care cuz the
adoptive parents were my parents and I
didn't think any other way I'd never met
my birth mother my brother had neither
but we're blood related so it's the same
mother I got the three little facts her
name where she used to live and her
maiden name it blew my mind that
honestly with like little tidbits of
information you could find someone on
the Internet Oh excited to go out with
my brother and take a journey and meet
her it's too early just Lee this is Doug
my brother same birth mother same
adoptive family I am a little nervous
basically uh get to kind of you know see
a different winds what my life could
have been what do you think of this
whole journey I think it's probably a
shitshow Pelley but I really hope it's
not cause like you guys don't deserve
that
and listen to the conversations that
you've had with her like I don't know
because she isn't something interested
in meeting guys yeah yeah it's the night
before we go and meet Suzanne my birth
mother and
feeling-wise I think I'm more nervous
than I've ever been about meeting
someone or doing something before we're
gonna understand where we came from and
why we were given up and why we were
lucky enough to be adopted by such a
great family but it was kind of hard to
get a read on her the last couple times
I talked to her on the phone because she
she just I don't know she didn't seem as
excited as Doug and I were we would be
like can't wait to see and she'd be like
oh okay
so I guess going into this I'm not
really sure where that we're mind is
that so we just got off the highway and
we're kind of in I guess Southwest
Pueblo I guess we'll park here and walk
in
Suzanne
which one are you I'm Robbie Doug how
are you this was me and my younger days
that's when you Christie was about seven
or eight this is Charlie when he was wow
that is that it was something uncanny
there's here's Pat I wouldn't have too
many pictures of him yeah see you're
gonna have no hair you're gonna do what
I do this is the first time I've ever
seen a picture of his her birth father
this is Chrissy when she is 17
my mother was very poor and she had
eight kids we ended up in a children's
home and my mother died at 16 then I got
involved with Pat which was train ride
through hell it's the only answer when
you guys came along you were supposed to
stay with me in this family and I had
Robby give you compared it wasn't an
accident
Robby wasn't an accident for me you know
I don't look at them as they're my kids
cuz they're not I look at myself as a
surrogate mother I was an instrument to
get them in here so they could get third
lesson he's done and so more strangers
is what we are I mean everything we know
about you at
we've learned in the past yeah when I
went to court for not court for the
judges train chamber for Robby the judge
says you have a you release all claims
to these kids and I thought that was
rotten because when we first made the
deal it was supposed to be an open
adoption and you through some and closed
it do you know why they did that yeah
because I was very unstable back at
those times and I know I was do you
think it was for the best that that
happened or probably so probably so
we're extremely thankful and grateful
for the chance that you gave us the
opportunity to do something at their
lives I'm happy to see where you're at
because you fulfilled my deal with God
because I wanted a better education a
better life with janitors gave you and
nice job
well yeah we'll definitely keep in touch
I feel good about the experience yeah it
was a great experience the thing that
sticks out the most was just her her
strength to be able to do this and to be
able to recognize it you know she was in
a very difficult situation and to be
able to look beyond that let's see what
you know she thought was a way out that
would uh that would give us a chance
just the strength to be able to do that
is very impressive to me I wouldn't mind
having her in my life
yeah and it's good to keep in touch with
her letter and know how we're doing she
did an amazing thing for us so if we can
get a little bit of a bag a little
anything I mean I think she more than
warrants it I think that we're smiling
after we do this says a lot about you
know how this weekend went